in this segment we make a connection
between the correlation coefficient and
some fairly realistic real-world
situations the bottom line will be that
the presence or absence of correlations
can make a huge difference
suppose that you run an investment
company that invests in real estate and
you have a hundred million of capital
that you want to invest now you have
learned or believed that it helps to
diversify to not put all of your eggs in
the same basket and for that reason
you're going to invest some of your
money in two different states you will
be investing in ten different states and
in each state you will invest ten
million so that your total investment is
spread between those ten states for each
state you have a model that tells you
that the return on your investment that
is your profit it's of course random but
you expect it to be 1 million on the
average that is in terms of the expected
value but there's also a fair amount of
randomness and so the standard deviation
is 1.3 now if you look at the one state
in isolation it would be a pretty risky
investment because the standard
deviation is comparable to the mean it's
not an unlikely event to have a return
that's one standard deviation below the
mean and if that happens your return is
going to be negative and you're losing
money but then you argue that you're
investing in ten different states yes
you might lose money in some of them but
overall you would expect to have a
pretty high confidence that you will end
up having a positive return is this
correct or not
let us do some calculations we will look
at the variance of your total return the
variance of a sum of random variables is
given by the formula that we have
developed it's the sum of the variances
but then you also have a bunch of
covariance terms that have to do with
the relation of the different random
variables now you make the assumption
that the different states are different
markets one doesn't affect the other so
that the excise are uncorrelated in that
case in this variance formula the
covariance terms are all zero and they
disappear and you're left with the sum
of ten variance terms now each one of
these variances is equal to the square
of the standard deviation and we have a
variance of 16.9 you then take the
square root to find the standard
deviation and the square root of this
number is 4.1 now your expected return
is equal to 10 which is two and a half
standard deviations you will only lose
money if the outcome is two and a half
standard deviations below the mean and
that's a fairly unlikely outcome and so
in this situation you feel very
confident that you will have a positive
profit suppose however that your
assumption is wrong and that actually
the different excise are correlated with
each other and suppose that the
correlation is pretty high point nine
essentially this means that the real
estate market in one state is strongly
related to the behavior of the market in
another state and that could be perhaps
because the markets in different states
are affected by some more global
phenomenon that operates on a national
level so in this case the covariance of
X I with XJ is going to be the
correlation coefficient times the
standard deviation of X I times the
standard deviation of XJ which is 0.9
times 1.3 times
1.3 and so the covariance to
to be 1.52
and in that case the variance of the sum
using this formula here is going to be
equal to 10 times the variance that you
have in each state which is 1.3 squared
plus you have a bunch of terms here how
many terms there's 90 of them and each
one of these terms is equal to one point
52 and the variance turns out to be a
hundred fifty four now you take the
square root of that and you find the
standard deviation of twelve point four
now your expected profit is ten but the
standard deviation is twelve point four
and if you happen to be one standard
deviation below the expectation which is
something that has a sizable probability
of occurring then your profit is going
to be negative so in the uncorrelated
case you're pretty certain that you will
have a positive profit but if the
correlations actually turn out to be
significant then you are facing a very
risky situation to some extent this is
similar to what happened during the
great financial crisis that is many
investment companies thought that they
were secure by diversifying and by
investing in different housing markets
in different states but then when the
economy moved as a whole it turned out
that there were high correlations
between the different states and so the
unthinkable that is large losses
actually did occur